turning now to Brazil where there is new
scrutiny on former president yair
bolsonaro after thousands of his
supporters stormed the country's
Democratic institutions on Sunday in
scenes eerily similar to January 6th
right here in this country bolsonaro is
currently in Florida and his advisors
have met with people close to former
president Trump Christina raffini is
following all this for us in Washington
Christina good morning
good morning Vlad will some U.S
lawmakers are already calling for
bolsonaro to be expelled from the U.S
but on Monday the former president
tweeted a picture of himself in a
hospital gown in a hospital bed in
Orlando saying he's being treated for
injuries to do with an old stabbing and
it doesn't look like he's going anywhere
anytime soon
to an American audience what happened in
Brazil Sunday might seem eerily familiar
an angry mob false accusations of a
stolen election and incalculable damage
to National institutions as well as the
government they represent the protests
in the capital Brasilia were in support
of former right-wing populist president
jair bolsonaro who lost the presidential
election last year to leftist Lula de
Silva terrific man he's done a fantastic
job sometimes called the Trump of the
tropics bolsonaro was an acolyte of the
former U.S president both in Manner and
strategy making false accusations of
election fraud and calling his opponents
criminals in Brazil it's gone beyond the
Boston Mars he's also received strong
supports and is the Washington Post
reports even advice from Trump Ally
Steve Bannon you use these machines use
the Judiciary to shut us down in the
media and we're not going to tolerate it
bolsonaro is currently in Florida having
left Brazil for a gated Orlando vacation
home just two days before President
Lula's inauguration as events unfolded
he denied encouraging the attacks
tweeting that while peaceful protests
are part of the democratic process
destruction and invasion of public
buildings are not there's no question
extremism is a factor in Brazilian
politics just as it is here Mike
McKinley was a career Diplomat and
served as ambassador to Brazil in the
Trump Administration there's a strong
Foundation
for bolsonarismo as they're calling it
to have a second life across the coming
years is bolsonarisma the Brazilian
equivalent of trumpism
it absolutely is as for bolsonaro
himself the U.S state Department says it
has not received any requests for Action
from Brazil Brazil's Democratic
institutions have our full support but
members of Congress including Texas
representative Joaquin Castro are
already objecting to Bolson Auto's U.S
state the United States should not be a
refuge for this authoritarian who has
inspired domestic terrorism in Brazil
now the state department wouldn't
comment directly on bolsonato's case but
said in general diplomats are here under
a 30-day visa and after that time period
he would have to reapply to DHS in order
to stay in the country Vlad
to be continued Christina thank you very
much